why is is now this moment in history the
right time for this why question
well what's so fascinating is that that
talk came out I'm you know in 2009 and
I've been giving that talk for 15 years
so when you talk about now it's been you
know it takes it takes a long time for
these things
exactly I I think there's there's two
parts to it which is
um you know for quite a long time you
know through the 80s 90s and and
especially 2000s as well
um we were very very finite minded in
our approach to business
um we saw the rise of using mass layouts
we saw the rise of shareholder Supremacy
all of these things didn't really exist
prior to the 80s and 90s they really
became popularized and we saw we started
to see an obsession with with
short-sightedness and it it came at a
cost it came across to our personal
health the longevity of a company the
quality of the culture
um how we felt about going to work and
it you know over the long run that had
massive implications for business as
well decline of uh loyalty amongst
employees also decline of innovation we
saw a decline of innovation over the
past few years as well
um uh so so it had it comes at a cost
not to mention our mental health right
and uh so I think two two things were at
play why that that talk matter number
one was I think we were starting to feel
the impact of that that finite business
model and we're looking for Alternatives
and I offered an explanation the other
reason is I took something that was
important but it sounded you know a
little bit hippie you know when I
purpose at work sounded so hippie back
then and I found a language I talked
talked about why that and grounded it in
the tenets of biology and I found a
language that made those who needed to
listen listen I wasn't just preaching to
the converted and I think that's one of
the the important things that it was
really about language